do you think many people will
realistically catch
i don't even know how to pronounce them
because i've only read that is it ba.1
is that how we pronounce it or is it ba1
the omacron variants do you know how do
we say it ba1 i don't know yeah so yeah
that's that okay do you think many
people will realistically catch ba1 and
then also ba2 or xe i feel like
authorities want us to think so
thank you
um
i'm very concerned that this thing came
out of a lab and therefore is not going
to abide by any of the normal rules and
intuitions
so you're talking about
two plus years ago not not also maybe
omicron being having come out of a
separate lab
omicron maybe possibly having come out
of separate lab is not required for your
concern to be salient not at all and in
fact there is a way in which the
weirdness of omicron
could be also a consequence of the
initial laboratory uh environment you
know in other words right
you
do serial passage in humanized mice it
escapes into
uh
human uh associated mice that's a large
population it makes changes it returns
to humans because you've increased its
tropism that kind of thing
but basically my feeling is
i think i hear almost everybody
trying to infer what's going to happen
based on the way these things tend to
behave and the problem is
the future won't look like the past if
this is the first time ever that you've
had a chimeric virus emerge right
globally it may tend
it may tend to revert to a normal state
right but
i believe we have done the worst thing
that we could do which is bridge a gap
it would not have jumped on its own and
having done so it is now
like an invasive in hawaii
yeah and so anyway i'm concerned that
the rules about natural immunity as much
as we saw them reflected in early phases
of this may break down
and i don't like it
yeah you wanna
you wanna say anything more about
about that
um
let's put it this way we have lots of
uh
pathogens that circulate by virtue of
some interaction between
uh
the way they produce natural immunity
that isn't maybe so effective and the
way they change and the inner you know
you keep getting colds for example and
some of that is you getting a descendant
of the pathogen you've already had which
would be better if you didn't um
so the question is did we fast forward
the process
what did we do here and
um
again i would um given the people we've
also talked about
not only is the tropism very very high
but the range of tissues that are
impacted by this thing is also
anomalously high for reasons that i
believe also have to do with the
laboratory origin and so um
you know what the hell anthony found you
yeah it's not
it's really not like
anything else
uh that we've seen
that we individually have experienced
and certainly and you know it's not
we can talk in terms of you know what's
the ifr you know the uh infection
fatality rate or the you know the cfr
compared to
other coronaviruses or flu for instance
and of course the comparison to flu
early on
was uh much lambasted and um and it
wasn't really appropriate then because
people were doing exactly the thing they
were conflating like does it have a
similar
um
effectively death rate that's a
simplification um to flu or does it not
and given that we live with flu what the
hell why are we shutting down things
over this that's that's a question
um that then tends to let people lead
people to think like well it's the flu
yes i know people die of the flu but
mostly they're very old is that true of
covid yes
but
if this is as frankly all the evidence
suggests it is a lab creation and given
that it causes
sets of symptoms that are not like
anything else
the you know the anosmia the the loss of
smell and taste that many people
experience the lesions that some people
get
the um
like the blisters on the i've never seen
or heard directly of anyone but um
people get on like the pads of their
fingers and toes
um the brain fog these aren't things
that you get with a cold whether the
coronaviruses they just they're not
things that you get with the flu right
these aren't you know these like one-off
very weird symptoms are the kinds of
things you expect from the kinds of
exotic tropical vector diseases like
mosquito vector diseases that we have
tried to protect ourselves against in
other places so um it's a it's a weird
exotic thing
that
if you're just counting deaths
doesn't seem to have a very high death
rate especially if you treat for it
but
what are the long-term effects of having
been exposed to it multiple times if you
end up with symptoms like what does it
persist in tissues does it take does it
affect longevity this is a question that
we don't hear people talking about yeah
or at least not very well and i would
if you take the model some model uh
i advanced back in the telomere days
which is that every disease
robs you of longevity right right
um you know even a common cold the point
is they don't typically rob you of very
much yeah
and if let's say that we talk about
every respiratory virus that you've had
in your life
everyone robs you of a little bit
because they take the tissues
that you depend on for respiration and
they
cause cells to die and have to be
replaced but well but so the argument
there though would would be contingent
on
they will they will have robbed you of
some life
if
it's those respiratory tissues
that reach the end of their you know hit
their hayflick limit
at first among all of your cells if
that's the thing that takes you out
exactly what i'm getting at is um
if you take every respiratory disease
that you've had and you imagine they all
rob you of some longevity but most
people don't die from the failure of
their lungs then the point is you don't
tend to see that effect very strongly
right it's there
but in the case of something like sars
kobe 2
which
impacts many many tissues and the
argument that i've put forward before is
that that's because if you
give this disease to a bunch of ferrets
in a cage in a laboratory they don't
have to keep functioning well as ferrets
in order to spread it unlike a wild
disease
that has to keep its host healthy enough
to to succeed so the anosmia in
particular
is conspicuous because a ferret that
can't smell probably starves to death
so the point is but a ferret in a cage
doesn't need the smell in order to find
its chow
so we may have created
symptoms that wouldn't accompany an
ordinary disease but the point is if the
thing is damaging lots of tissues around
the body
right then the point is it's not like a
respiratory virus where you have to
ultimately die of the failure of your
lungs in order to see the effect it's
had on your longevity the point is if
it's expiring you know a little bit of
liver a little bit of i don't know what
tissues it's affecting but many many
tissues by virtue of the way it
interfaces with circulation and the
point is well you're going to die of the
failure of one of those things aren't
you right and if you do you know you
don't have to cancer is sort of the
opposite of the failure of these systems
but you're very likely to die from the
failure of some system right
it's going to be something like half of
deaths that are not the result of trauma
right
so
if that's the case then the chances that
it will burn some of the
longevity you had in that tissue are
high which means the effect on longevity
is going to be much
more widespread right
and that's associated with the
prediction that there will be an
increase in cancers across many systems
so it also seems to be somehow
liberating cancers that people had that
were functioning very slowly or things
that were prototumors and things like
that so you basically have cancer and
failure of an organ as opposite failure
modes right
and both of these things seem to be
impacted
um by this disease so anyway it's a very
it's a very frightening disease i did
want to correct one thing though you
said this loss of taste and smell
now absolutely people lose their sense
of smell but i think a lot of the people
who say they've lost their sense of
taste never had taste in the first place
oh okay i stand corrected
i was talking to a wonderful woman this
week who who um i assure you did and she
now has it again
um
but did in fact lose both and she had
taste in both senses of the word really
yes oh yes that's like it's like a
redundant backup sense of taste yeah
um
no no not at all different different
totally different same spellings
[Music]
you